oh my goodness
i mean come on
i think you said there needs to be some
litigation there should be some
litigation just look at that people have
stopped me saying would you want to sell
that watch
no pretty good knockoff teddy totally
[Music]
mr wonderful here in another episode of
what i'm calling wine and watches why
because wine making is art and just for
shameless promotion this is o'leary fine
wines we're trying we're trying my pinot
noir which is very very hard to make
teddy's loving it i can tell you right
now but also we're talking about
physical art that's watches now i wanted
to challenge teddy because he's been so
good at finding great value because one
of the challenges in watch collecting is
if you're getting into the higher end
pieces you're spending 100 200 250 000
and the aftermarket is up to half a
million and that's not affordability
whatsoever but i want to encourage
people to start collecting so here's a
really interesting idea i said to teddy
look let me bring out some of my mega
pieces the monsters the beasts the ones
that are impossible to get that traded
crazy prices and you find the
equivalents at affordable prices so if
you can't afford
a rolex submariner is there something
that's close to it that teddy can find
and i think we've nailed it so let's get
at it teddy you start
show me something in let's go with the
classic uh
rolex daytona oh it's daytona yeah
there's wait let me show you a rolex
daytona a crazy rolex daytona like the
classic
blackface daytona
you can't even get this if you wanted it
so hard it's a beautiful watch and
secondary market's a ridiculous price
that's the problem yeah it's approaching
40. yeah it's about 40 000 or 38 40 000
obviously this one has a red band it's a
shark tank watch
i don't think you should buy a forty
thousand dollar watch in the aftermarket
if you get something equivalent what do
you got teddy
so this was a tough one because you
could go
really dead on the daytona but then you
could also look at the design attributes
that make the daytona the daytona and
i'm going back more to like the maybe
older reference daytona
kind of yes that's what i'm going for
those old classic mid 20th century
that's where the brand got established
the big red they call it now all that
yeah yes exactly and
the brand here i would say on anything
on the table this is a brand with a ton
of cachet in the arena of chronographs
and that's hamilton
i believe that it's a hamilton this is a
hamilton what's the price point two
thousand dollars just over two thousand
dollars so this
is a watch that takes a lot of influence
from the chronomatics from hamilton now
hamilton was involved in the autumn
suggesting that rolex ripped off
hamilton i'm not saying somebody ripped
somebody off well here i'll let's get
the hit looks a lot like if i if i was
looking back 20 feet from that i'd say
oh that's a rolex big red let's get the
history right so back in 1969 all the
brands were scrambling to make the first
automatic chronograph you had the likes
of breitling you had the likes of hoyer
you had the likes of uh zenith with the
el premiero all were going after it also
seiko with the 6139
hamilton was also involved with hoyer as
well as breitling in making the first
automatic codement involved with what
were they so they all collaborated their
own technologies their own just uh minds
to allow them to actually create the
first automatic chronograph movement in
1969 so
this watch stems from those creations
and this is known as the intramatic it's
two thousand dollars swiss made the
design attribute that i like about this
is so many people that and they talk
about panda panda dials right you got
they got the sub registers
i think it's one of the best executions
that you're gonna find and it also does
have true history i didn't want to go
for a complete knockoff here this is the
brand it's pretty close
it's got its own history no question
about it i don't think anybody gets
street cred for having its own history
but clearly these makers started to
really
groove off each other it reminds me i
see more breitling and hoyer in that
design that i do it reminds me of
certain blues riffs and guitars they've
been around since the 50s everybody rips
from everybody sure you know got
zeppelin playing the blues rips
and then you give a little riff to
change a little bit but this is a
classic chronograph uh made very famous
by early rolexes back in the 60s i mean
this is it's a great piece at that price
is fantastic can't go wrong 2000 bucks
love the band too
it's a great bracelet okay that's good
i'm going to throw something at you all
right
this is perhaps one of the most coveted
watches
in the world the ap jumbo royal oak okay
now of course made with a red band for
mr wonderful this is a shark tank watch
and this is a beautiful red band that's
integrated right to the to the case in a
gorgeous way that blue dial that classic
design
um
not approachable in price anymore no
it's gone bonkers it's gone bonkers but
what do you got that's even closing in
on that i'm interested to see what you
think about this one because this is
where i would start you're getting
almost into the homage territory and
this is a marisa claw icon oh my
goodness
i mean come on
i think you said there needs to be some
litigation there should be some
litigation just look at that look at
that
so i mean if you can't get that you got
to get this this is crazy the only
thing's on this what would you say it is
i don't know 5 000 2 thousand bucks less
than two thousand wow finishing on the
bracelet it does have it doesn't have
the screws it has kind of more of those
grip clips
it's right there it is it is definitely
off the theme that's a nice piece
from finishing perspe that is when
people talk about the ap royal elope
what can i get i don't have the money
for it i got two grand to spend or maybe
maurice lacroix
smith brand put those two together just
look at that i mean it's
i mean you can never make it should be
never make a shortcut for the real thing
if you can't afford it responsibly but
if you can't i mean this is they've
created i cannot endorse the secondary
market on the jumbo anymore it's gone
too crazy it's nice and it's i can't
tell you how many people have stopped me
saying would you want to sell that watch
no because i can never replace it
and i am a huge proponent of go save for
the real thing do it responsibly but
they've made it so you can't do it
responsibly so you have to look
elsewhere now that just is what it is
but i got i mean this is one of my go-to
pieces i wear it all the time it it just
looks timeless it's timeless it's a
great design but this is a great it's
inspired movement
or should i say dial it's sort of really
uh okay that's good that's a pretty good
knockoff teddy
that's pretty good right around the okay
word where are we gonna go next where do
you want to go next you tell me well
let's go um
i don't know let me try something on you
here
um
let's go patek
you you know this piece right 57-26 the
26
crazy piece to get i do not have a red
band on this i cannot wear it on
television but i do wear it for dinner
all the time and people love it i like
the symmetry of the 26 i really do it's
class with the moon phase the moon phase
looks great on the nautilus it really
works
what do you got to even come close to
this well i don't have a moon phase
because that's going to cost us a little
extra but i think from the silhouette of
the case you got the bracelet you have
these kind of central polish link to
kind of go with that design i want to
look at this this is frederie constant
the high life that is not inexpensive
though is it
what do you think it is four thousand
two thousand dollars you're kidding i
mean these are nailing me on price i
mean they're still expensive these are
aspirational pieces for many people out
there oh nice style whoa
look at the etching on that the globe eh
cosc uh chronometer
i mean that's
there's a chance it could be even more
accurate than your patek i bet if we put
in a timeline yeah it could be it could
be it's not a patek but it is pretty
damn nice and it's kind of got that blue
thing going on
winner winner chicken bracelet's very
nice too i was impressed with that one
and it's the one i will say about that
is it's not so much on the nose compared
to some of the other designs here like
the maurice the qual you know it's
getting a little you know careful there
with how they're encroaching on the
design of the ap that's a little bit
more of its own thing let me throw
another challenge at you i like it the
most coveted watch for many many sports
enthusiasts is the rolex submariner
not approachable anymore in secondary
market not even available in primary
market
the classic steel blackface impossible
to get it doesn't matter who you are now
that watch has just gone into the
stratosphere
and it's i don't know why nobody can
really say why because it's a production
model
but it is become
after the daytona the go-to rolex what
do you got that could satisfy demand
there so i struggled with this one a
little bit because there's probably a
number of suitable options here
everybody knocks it off yes but i wanted
to go for something that i think
represents the same level of
this design it's contemporaneous
approach it's well built ceramic bezel
nice bracelet and it's still a nice dive
watch it's a little more unaffordable
relatively a true dive watch you can get
and a true dive watch and a true dive
watch i wouldn't say this is the most
affordable option but i think it's a
definitive dive watch in its price range
can i say
would you agree with me sure that pretty
well every brand makes a knockoff
submariner
somebody mentioned to me they said the
most overrated watch is the rolex
submariner and i agreed but i kind of
disagreed because the thing that makes
people fatigued about the submariner is
because they see it from rolex all the
time they hear about it all the time but
they also see it almost everywhere else
it's probably one of the most successful
designs in history it's coveted as a
sports piece it's coveted as a dive
watch it's coveted as a
you know collector's item and it looks
great in formal wear i mean it really
really covers the bases just because
something's so great i mean is that a
knock on it you know i always think
about that i use an example it's tiring
to see it on everything there's wrist in
one
iteration or another but i think it is
the most knocked off look in all of
watch history you see it everywhere it's
ubiquitous yeah
but this is now i'm seeing it again
see i don't think so well it's slightly
different it's got more of a of a
cylindrical look to it the shape
something's pretty different you have
the oyster case the oyster silhouette is
maybe one outside of maybe panerai
perhaps the most recognizable silhouette
you're gonna find
it's the aorus aquas now aorus is a
brand they're
i know the overspread but i mean they're
probably one of the largest
independently run brands from more of a
mass market perspective not a huge mass
market but they're in the hundreds of
millions in sales i would imagine they
do quite well so it's made timepieces i
say the aqueous is the definitive choice
for two thousand dollars now that one
there you can get it available with a
manufactured caliber movement which is a
little bit more expensive it's just over
three yeah when you get it with the
salina movement on the inside you can
get it for just around two what do you
recommend
you know
they've been on the market for enough
time i think with if you buy it from an
authorized dealer i would go for the
10-year warranty that comes with the
horus aqueous if you'd like the oros
aqueous design if you only have 2000
bucks to spend i think you're not really
sacrificing the theme of a dive watch
here it is it's got some seiko-esque
elements too we could definitely pull
out a seiko and say that as the
definitive choice but i just liked how
this had more of a contemporary modern
feel to it it just felt more subtle but
it's not right there black on black with
the popping white uh you know
i mean
it gives it that rolexy vibe but at the
same time it's got heritage with seiko
if you'll ask me i mean it's got a combo
of the two brands here
it's different and it's different and
it's standing on its own screwdriver
screw down crown 300 meters of water
resistance sapphire crystal now that is
a manufactured movement that's the
caliber 400 in there exactly yeah it has
a 10 i mean it has a five-day power
reserve
teddy you're bringing great value here
so i mean
clearly you know um i can't tell you how
many people say can you get me a
submariner can you give me a steel
submarine with black dial i mean come on
it's just it's never ending
let's go to a dress watch a classic
cartier
which is no longer affordable either
whether you're going into the gold or
you mean the trouble is the watch market
has left millions of people behind yeah
and it's it's it's wrong and it's you
know celebrating the art of mechanical
watches um
taking away affordability is done what
do you got that could emulate cartier
so for cartier i think
the best option here and this is not i
would say a direct kind of knock off in
any way i think this has its own design
dna and that's from long gene it's a
brand that we
really enjoy this is known as adult
videos she's been around long enough did
they emulate that design they have in
their own archive i mean there's a lot
of people making this rectangular design
because cartier's johnny come lately on
the watch scene if you think about it
i mean outside of the tank and the
santos i mean the santos has history
next to pretty much every i mean every
single wrist watch could fall behind the
scenes
the rest of the designs are relatively
new yes the blues of the world the roses
it's more considered jewelry than
collectibility although i have many
cartier's because they're gif you know
in business they're often gifted and
inscribed on and et cetera et cetera i
have many for that
but the tank is classic this is more
cartier tank american so it has that
kind of more rectangular case than
square so it's a curve that cartier
doesn't have yeah which it has the curve
back as well so it's going to really sit
on the wrist well take a look at that i
mean i just think that that i mean also
oh
that's so take a look i thought it was a
car shape
right out of the way but also can you
see where they can maybe get some of the
inspiration from their own archive let
me take a look at the second see what i
mean like look at that sector dial
they kind of adapted that yeah i see it
beautiful piece beautiful
and and what i like about this is
price point 1500 bucks long jeans not a
jewelry brand they're they're true
watchmaker they have one of the richest
archives of any brand out there people
don't know that about login they really
don't to me seiko and largine are the
best value in the industry in terms of
getting great pieces
longines is huge in asia it's a massive
massive brand globally but not so much
yet
in north america
left behind a little bit but that's a
great piece
it really is class they're class and
it has street cred in that they had that
design in their own archives right
exactly all right what else you got
so we have two left on the table now
you mentioned the submariner but you
could argue that maybe number two if not
number one another one that you see
everywhere from a design perspective
from rolex
the datejust yeah datejust is probably
the most classic go-to and of late which
really surprises me
my daughter my wife they want to wear
these larger sized they just and as a
result
it's found its way into the unisex
market like where girlfriend boyfriend
kind of thing and made it very popular
obviously
it's so rolexy it's insane and there
should be litigation
so the bezels absolutely were okay
are you kidding like are you kidding
they call it what it is it's a it's a
fluted bezel it's a ripoff it's a fluted
bezel this is probably not the best
representation of tiso because they
originally had like a hobnail bezel on
this watch and then they switched it
over to this diluted battery to rip off
the vibe oh it's a datejust no question
about it in many ways but
first of all i will say you know take a
look at it though just to backtrack a
little bit so is it high quality i would
you mentioned long jean i would throw in
a seiko i would throw tiso and hamilton
also but they put the 1853 on this
look at that dial by the way
i don't know you want to backtrack a
little bit oh my goodness that's a nice
piece but cosc certified so you're
getting accuracy here
yeah i mean look this is playing off
another brand in some ways but so
there's
one of my very very first watches when i
was gifted when i was 16 years old was
the tiso
bought in geneva
and at that time was considered a very
credible piece as it is today if you're
looking at value at a premium brand if
you're looking at value and they
understand that they're the entry door
entry door for swiss watch making it's
nice i got to tell you teddy that's
what's the price out of this together
what do you think it is
3 000.
995 bucks
pretty good right over pricing
everything you are yeah because they're
really good these are good that that's a
great classic dress piece
great bracelet
beautiful dial clean good contrast
great deal and they drop the fluted
bezel you wouldn't be saying the same
things about pulling from rolex as much
but that's what makes it a good
inclusion for a video like this it looks
like the datejust that's a total rip-off
you got one more i do have one more okay
i think we know where this one's pulling
inspiration from
can you tell me
it's a ripoff of omega
speedmaster all right so let's let's a
complete ripoff okay all right well i'm
going to answer that so
1971.
astronaut david scott yeah
mission went to this went to the moon
there's omega speedmaster failed him
he brought his own personal belief i
prefer that story not get out this watch
is a direct
creation from that david scott warren
watch on the moon where he actually did
his moonwalk that's known as the bull of
a lunar pilot we actually showed you
this one before how much do you think
that one is
well i'm gonna start going down the
feeding chain how about 2 500.
still overshot it i'm kidding
like 500 to 600 depending on the strap
option you go forward and where's the
movement from so that is so they're
owned by citizen groups so japan is
who's making those movements yeah
so it's it's really a japanese movie
it's a japanese movement and that's a
high performance quartz movement so it's
going to have
the oscillation rate it's going to just
absolutely dwarf traditional quartz in
terms of attacks
it's beautiful i mean look i it's a
great if you're not going to step up and
buy the omega speedmaster which has
become very popular of late absolutely
i'm a huge speedmaster fan yeah so
speedmaster was in the doldrums for a
while and i don't know what happened but
maybe the snoopy or whatever it is it
occurred
it's exploded to the upside now and also
that affiliation with james bond he
could help them yeah with the sea master
i think what happened was they updated
the speed master i think they
totally re defined the design had some
good limited edition releases and omega
was getting lost in the early 80s
yes they were they fell in hard times i
think what actually happens is they're
reaping a lot of the benefits of rolex
pissing off their consumer base as well
i think people are like wait
omega they make superb watches what am i
paying all this extra money for what am
i waiting around also about availability
go into a rolex boutique anywhere
absolutely there's nothing there you're
just whistling in the wind i mean
there's no inventory and so and that's a
problem that's a problem you're going to
piss off a lot of concerns yeah rolex
makes millions of watches they do yeah
well they haven't they people are saying
800 000 to a million a year that's what
they say the outfit is nobody knows
i wouldn't i wouldn't doubt you the
demand is nuts right now for them
well
look i'm gonna this is actually a very
very good buy for what it is i think
it's a great piece so you've really
delivered today teddy we went really
high-end crazy prices
and you've come up with iterations at
affordable entry levels which is really
important that's you're delivering value
there there's no question about it and i
will say one thing i just want to show
you something i don't think that you've
seen
um new to my collection has not been
adopted yet with a red band but
do you know the minerva movement it's
it's actually
it's its heritage comes from
a stopwatch and you see the top plunger
this measures
actually a hundredth of a second
yeah i have to wind it it's lost its
power but i'll tell you something
i'm going to convert this to a red band
and i think it's going to be just
absolutely fantastic no question about
it on the other hand look how big it is
it's huge
i just wanted your comments on it just
while we're missing i mean the one thing
that i'll say about i think i mentioned
this to you is like 100th of a second on
a larger display like that that's when
it becomes useful i think this is some
you have your cenograph which is cool
but
just seeing that
just visual of the scene you have to fly
around it's amazing yeah that's just new
to my collection um moblaw now owns it
which is a you know a company that makes
pens i collect their pens
but they're keeping the heritage of the
making of the minerva the same
sounds like a swarm of locusts i know i
know but look at the movement and it's
beautiful
it is crazy
so you know value-wise unfortunately
these watches price points are 50 60 70
000
but
it's hard to find a centigraph at a low
price that's the problem sure
that's your next challenge that's why i
brought it out next time we meet you
find me something in the center graph at
a price you can be an entry level
that's a challenge but that's that's
that is the challenge because
centrographs are rare they're hard to
make
um they're complex movements but if
you'll do your work maybe you can come
up with something
my homework to do it's never-ending
teddy thank you very much for the final
job today absolutely now you know what
you can get at entry level to emulate
crazy watch prices do not buy these do
not buy them a secondary market i forbid
you
take care